the mountains of northern iraq hide some
of europe's most wanted men
the smuggling gangs that helped
thousands of people on the dangerous and
illegal journeys into britain france and
elsewhere on the continent
after days of negotiation a major
smuggler here has agreed to meet us
he has strict terms we must reveal
nothing about his identity or location
he won't even come outside with us in
case he is seen by neighbors and
reported to the undercover police
he's on edge but happy to talk and what
he reveals is that britain's rwanda
policy so controversial back in europe
could
so you think it could be quite an
effective policy if it is enacted
properly
there is
if i can put it like this a war going on
at the moment between the governments
particularly france and britain and the
smugglers
who's going to win that war
the british government say that you're a
murderer the french government
say that you're a murderer the families
that we've spoken to of people who have
died trying to cross into europe they
say you're a murderer
we get a call telling us that a second
smuggler will now meet with us he's in a
nearby town and insists we interview him
in a car so we're not spotted
[Music]
foreign
but for now there's no let up in the
number of people wanting to leave here
for europe
every street in this town seems to know
someone who has gone or wants to go all
for their own reasons
say their lives are at risk because of a
family feud
i mean
[Music]
even if the british government starts
deporting migrants to rwanda in large
numbers
it won't stop people trying to leave
here they'll just go elsewhere
as one of the smugglers told us close
down one route and another will just
open up
aleister bunker sky news in northern
iraq